foreign
so I get to go to the French Riviera on
the Isis dime to do what wanting to go
to the French Riviera I mean you might
run into French people and a surprising
amount of the British don't
underestimate Scorpio what Clint
Eastwood told the studio when they
freaked out about the budget for his
first Dirty Harry movie somehow makes
its way into this episode so tell tile
is terrible for a kitchen because it's
so porous well this just sounds like you
didn't use a proper sealer on your tiles
Mister well they just taped something
already this book is all Laura mipsum
and Archer doesn't even once comment on
all the instances of the word comb if
this pineal pregnancy test is a joke or
I've been very wrong about how these
things work for a very long time either
way this thing is the lack of
information I received from my high
school health class like which end are
you supposed to blow into this was uh
supposed to be coconut shrimp all the
way off with coconut shrimp there is no
way anyone likes it you're mixing the
terrible Taste of coconut with the
deliciousness of shrimp and why would
you [__] do that you monster I really
want it well too bad because guess what
so if Lotto is getting this assignment
the whole time why is Mallory wasting
all this time telling Archer about the
mission even for Mallory this seems out
of character I can't imagine she'd want
to waste the time it would take to
humiliate archer in this way however it
does work out conveniently for Archer
that he knows exactly where to go and
what to do when Lana needs rescuing so
here's one send for the convenience and
another five for making this mother-son
talk Peta on for all the sometime why
are you going I'm going to
um a conference oh well isn't that
convenient Archer I already stand the
convenience of this situation and yes
technically your convenience is a
different convenience than my
convenience so that's really [__]
convenient so I moved in with my last
girlfriend after four weeks what are you
a lesbian the sin is obviously using
stereotypes instead of surround sound
types but in all my research into you
hauling I couldn't find a single reason
why other companies were passed up we
could have had pen skiing rydering or
even budgeting but even though Cyril may
be clingy oh Saran Wrap could take a
lesson you used to complain wait did
Mallory and Lana just stop talking about
serial mid-conversation in the limo and
then continue from where they left off
once they got on the plane those are
several minutes of silence I'd be super
curious to watch I wonder if he's like
that because I used to spank him with a
wooden spoon uh yeah I don't know about
that but it might explain the ping pong
paddle you never need to explain a ping
pong battle but sometimes you do need to
explain the balls it better be Mr sex
tape title of the documentary about my
sex tape scuff that luggage and I'll cut
your hamstrings for you half of these
boxes appear to be Mallory's kit yet the
episode doesn't contain a drum solo I'm
sorry are you addressing me because your
Authority is not recognized in Fort
kickex Krieger would be the kickassiest
to TV sins texture again I am if you'd
shut up do I think Cyril can be
extremely dumb yes do I think Cyril's
dumb enough to let Archer's obvious
backhanded sabotage attempts be
successful I mean most days probably but
today I'm not buying it for some reason
I'm a complicated sinner which hopefully
explains my shock at finding myself
about the chum guzzler I get that your
Chum is mostly water but guzzling isn't
entirely unnecessary in the flavor
Department a little goes a long way
worst case scenario her cover got blown
in Scorpios ripping her senseless before
he chops her battered corpse into fish
food Archer says something shockingly
awful because he has no filter and no
real understanding of right or wrong and
the audience is supposed to find it
funny just because it's a terrible thing
to say cliche what is in this drink
sorry is ice from cooler somehow it got
the butter all over it the answer is
that everything in France is
inexplicably slathered in butter
oh dear God Mallory thinks Lana is in
immediate danger and her solution is to
call Archer who's hours away back in the
U.S to come in on a rescue mission and
we're supposed to not question any of
this because the defining trade of this
company is them all being bad at their
jobs because it would be nice to know
what kind of danger I'm facing here and
it would be nice to know why Archer
passed up an opportunity to say danger
zone I bet Mr Archer already went all
double O Ninja on Scorpio's ass
karate sound I was appropriately
ridiculed by The Neighborhood kids for
mouthing sound effects on the basketball
court so even though we're Kindred
Spirits I must send Krieger because
there isn't even any karate happening
right now
[Applause]
the celebration I'm legally no longer
allowed to do when entering the
gelateria somehow makes its way into the
episode I thought I gave you a fake
number episode expects us to believe
that Archer can get cell phone service
underwater and I do not believe you
episode I've had good results with ether
having good results with ether I am just
now in
[Music]
now I get my balls again that didn't
sounds like he shaved his balls at least
six or eight times in close succession
and I feel sorry for them what was that
all about
um since Lana has no way of knowing that
Mallory has been watching her until now
how would she know that this was the
moment that made Mallory think she was
in trouble I mean just because she's
right doesn't make it any less [__]
that she knew no excuses eh my balls are
smooth even without hair on them your
balls should not be smooth right
Bartleby the scrivener anybody not a big
Melville crowd here huh one thing
Scorpio and I have in common well that
and super smooth balls that got a little
dark I mean yeah chocolate fondue
threesome Hardy hard but what I really
want to know is how Archer kept the fake
mustache on through all of this because
that shit's impressive this chocolate
covered strawberry was not there before
the commercial adding to the overall
number of chocolate covered questions we
have every single noun and verb in that
sentence totally arouses me logophilia
is never going to have a more mainstream
appeal with Krieger Azar I mean your
spokesperson every Isis agent has a
company issued life insurance policy and
uh and what
now both groups talking about life
insurance and
how'd you get life insurance Lana don't
they know you're in the danger zone too
late Archer two [__] late I forgot to
spend the balance in my God
episode has time for this despite his
multiple holes Archer will continue to
function normally
lawn and Archer then have a lengthy back
and forth in these guys forget how to
shoot or something Lana
[__] they survived this because the
episode is running out of time so they
have to just be better than the bad guys
that not exploding remember Cheryl is
just a cartoon remember Cheryl is just a
cartoon remember [__] you can trust me
Cheryl gives a call back to something
that Lana said earlier in the episode
and Cheryl was not around to hear it but
I mean I'm feeling a little generous
today so I probably won't send the
episode for this one little thing womp
womp
fish everywhere so I get to go to the
French Riviera on the Isis time to do
what I just want to say one word to you
Plastics
the Pope's fault she won't let me wear a
condo this is what
yeah I want it you really really really
no you go have a fun assassination I'll
have fun watching you oh so I can rub
myself into your crotch drinking
champagne in a bikini is there any other
way now how's my disguise that is your
worst disguise yet every single noun and
verb in that sentence totally arouses me
not sexual let me finish
also not sexual